out of this stunning story out of
Washington a Maryland man arrested when
he showed up her work at the White House
is due in court today in an attempted
murder case
The Secret Service arrested 29-year old
Marty's Edwards at a checkpoint after
learning he was wanted in connection
with the shooting Paula Reid broke the
story and she's at the White House where
Edwards was cleared to work as a
contractor for the National Security
Council Paula good morning good morning
the Secret Service says it was notified
on Monday that Edwards was wanted on an
outstanding warrant for first-degree
attempted-murder out of Prince George's
County Maryland these charges stem from
a May third domestic shooting involving
an ex-girlfriend and her current
boyfriend who was shot but according to
police the ex-girlfriend didn't report
the incident until May 17th and a
warrant was entered into the national
registry the next day yesterday around
noon
Edwards showed up here for work and was
arrested by the Secret Service outside
the Northwest visitor entrance while the
Secret Service routinely checks the
White House pass holder information
against a criminal database that check
doesn't happen every time someone comes
through that gate and it is not known
exactly what Edwards did here at the
White House or how many times he came to
work since that warrant was issued three
weeks ago John all of thanks